foreign
[Music]
friends we are living in a world which
is evolving very fast
Technologies and trends that we see
today are going to change the way we
live work and also how we interact with
our customers users and employees
Technologies like chat GPT advances in
healthcare data science a truly game
changing
but now you need an expert to really use
them in your company for your benefit
and it's easier said than done
as a matter of fact
providing timely expert help
is the biggest challenge for many many
organizations today whether it's for
your customers or for for your internal
employees
8.5 trillion dollars will be
unrecognized in revenues because of this
Talent shortage
and as per Gartner
64 percent of emerging technologies will
never be used because we don't have the
expertise to even adopt them
so how are some of the leading
organizations thinking about it
well I had the unique privilege of
talking to 30 plus top leaders and three
months of research when I was building
my startup and I want to share today
what I learned from them a gist of that
I have summarized them into three
different things collaboration
Automation and incentivization
meaningful incentivization and I bring
upon two companies which you know very
well NASA and AWS
so NASA has started something called
Center for collaborative innovation
where NASA Engineers can talk to
external experts and solve complex
projects not only they are bringing out
great Technologies they are actually
saving millions of dollars because they
are collaborating with external folks
with their internal teams that's an
internal facing Network
AWS which is known for its customer
centricity has opened up AWS IQ Network
where their customers can go and hire
any AWS expert today and get their
projects done faster
so my friends if you haven't done so yet
I think it's time for you to build your
expert Network for your company and your
company is going to thank you for that
just keep three things in mind
collaborate
bring internal and external stakeholders
in the mix so you can innovate better
automate bring Ai and the human
intelligence together so you can scale
better and then incentivize not just
with money but with purpose so you can
sustain it better
so what I suggest
have a place where you have a database
of your experts experts.yourcompany.com
it could be an external facing experts
it could be or it could be employee
facing experts so next time a customer
says hey do you have an expert in your
product in let him you point them to
that place
if you have an internal facing experts
domain then your employees can go and go
to a single place and say okay that's
where I find an expert and these experts
could be internal or external
and then you combine the power of human
knowledge and AI by bringing in three
elements out of it make it a really good
portal where you can manage them on
board them get the payments done no more
Learning and Development kind of a
mindset very different bring AI to
automate it the time is precious for
these experts but there are many tools
today so you can make bang for the buck
so when some experts come in you can
have an insights out of it you can have
summarization of the entire thing in
there and lastly bring it to the flow of
work where you can integrate with where
you are interacting with your customers
or your employees like your slack
Microsoft teams or whatever you are
using today
and if you do it right you are not just
going to make it impactful you are going
to drive growth by getting things done
for your customers or for employees you
will scale it better by bringing an
internal as well as your external
experts into one place so you can
innovate better and then you will drive
growth you will drive revenue and you
will make a big impact in your company
and as a true leader I want to bring it
home
I want to have a Stanford lead expert
connect
where 5000 of us who bring in tremendous
knowledge in various departments various
categories could be a part of this
network out here
my hope is that at some point we will
have 25 odd categories from blockchain
to healthcare to anywhere else where any
leader
if they have a need in their company
they can call upon another leader
through this network
and the way it works is very simple you
post a project if you have an estimated
budget in mind send that to the right
category and it gets to everyone else in
there
if you want to be a participant into
this if you want to learn more please go
to bitly.expert networks lead
but my friends knowledge is truly
precious let's make it very valuable
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]